if you told me three days ago that I
would be in Italy with a handsome blah
blah I would say you are crazy but here
I am
hello your grandfather is dead I don't
even know him well flyer to Italy I live
a very boring life I can't just get on a
plane to Rome you have to go
my dying wish is that you be the new
boss
of the volcano family
I was told I would be meeting with the
new paltan of family box yeah that's
right Kristen the new boss how are we
supposed to appear strong when she is
dead would you say that to a male my
boss
I'm more of a cherry jello person uh no
limoncello
the poison I put your drink you'll be
traveling to Your Heart by now
am I okay right I switched our glasses
while you're on the phone I'm so sorry
[Music]
portion and I didn't know if I was gonna
like limoncello oh and I didn't want to
be rude
[Music]